so i know you're a sit back and watch a
burn type of guy for the decline my
question to you yep my question for you
is
what's your you know [ __ ] hits the fan
plan what do you do once it actually
goes all the way to health
well
the only things that i see that are that
are going to be a
uh
s h t
f scenario okay which is uh
which is what you describe
[ __ ] things like extinction level
events
meteors comets hitting the earth
um
war would def like a serious war would
definitely do something like that i
don't think the us is going to pick a
fight with china or russia they just
they just like it's just something that
they're not going to win military
advisers will not lean into that very
strongly like the us is only going to
pick fights with people they
they think they can dominate and by the
way the track record of the us military
over the last few years kind of sucks
you know aka vietnam aka korea aka you
know afghanistan like you know you can
go right down the list like there's not
been a lot of very you know successful
wins with the exception of you know
world war ii
um
well don't you see a lot of the uh
same division and issues that say you
know i'm a fan of history that you've
seen in ancient rome happening a lot in
america now
yeah like all civil all civilizations
you know have a rise and a decline we
saw it with the roman empire with the
ottoman with the greek with the mayans
like all of these had great like there's
um you know if you're a fan of history
there's uh
a monolithic site that they're
excavating in turkey called back go
beckley tepe i don't know if you've
heard of it
i have massive massive uh graham graham
hancock has a lot of videos and talks on
it but all of these great civilizations
have left behind something and they've
eventually kind of like you know
disappeared um i think the western
civilization that we live in today is
eventually going to decline and
disappear as well and be replaced by
something else but
i mean [ __ ] hits the fan well
are you able to feed yourselves you know
are you able to
you know find or make clean drinking
water are you able to protect your
family
you know with your hands or with you
know weaponry like those are the things
that you want to prepare for and i'm not
going to talk about what i've done
because you shouldn't be giving away
what your
what your plan is publicly because then
you're giving away intel to the
opposition right right but there's a lot
of stuff out there like there's a lot of
prepping sites there's a lot of guys
that talk about you know what you should
be stacking and you know how you should
prepare for it so
i wouldn't go head over heels and spend
all like some people go batshit crazy
with that and they'll
just dig a giant hole in their backyard
and they'll drop a shipping container in
there and they'll turn it into like a
sleeping quarters with like you know
you know circulated fresh air with hvac
and everything plugged in and they got
weaponry and food for years and all that
sort of stuff you can go that far but
i don't see the need for it but yeah
as a guy
i believe and i didn't add it there but
an unplugged alpha would have a a plan
right right again the second part is
just sharing i think
i've never had an issue getting women or
being in relationships etc but i think
in my marriage so i've been married just
shy ten years that i definitely would
see some tendencies of betazation by a
thousand concession concessions i think
that's right it's just to what degree
yeah i think that's what i gained the
most value out of your book from was
realizing that and noticing that and
then changing my behavior especially
with my wife and children not just
letting things slide like i could easily
do and and then there'd be times where
i'd see my wife would call me an a-hole
and actually put a smile on my face
because i'm like okay means i'm not just
falling back into old like ruts and
traps and letting just things go i'm
like that's i take that as a good thing
so yeah good i appreciate the book it's
been awesome all right man thanks hey
and do me a solid guys if you've read
the book leave a written review on
amazon and let guys know what value you
got out of it it just helps them you
know when they go through it's like okay
yeah you know these guys are all saying
something positive it just helps me out
we'll do thanks man thank you
you